bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre sur TV
film nouvelle édition du 7 8 nous allons
faire le tour ensemble de l'actualité
locale avec nos invités notamment Jérôme
André président d'achève prévention
bonsoir bonsoir également à Xavier
recoquet et merci de venir sur ce
plateau pour témoigner vous êtes
séropositifs depuis 1987 le 5 avril
c'est le coup d'envoi du Sidaction et le
mot d'ordre cette année restez vigilant
il est 18h si vous nous suivez en direct
voici déjà les titres de cette édition
du 3 avril le premier jour d'ouverture
pour le ciné 7 à Élancourt après plus de
deux ans de travaux et de nombreux
retards et les réactions des nouveaux
spectateurs à l'issue de la première
séance de cet après-midi
soigner le décrochage scolaire par le
théâtre c'est l'initiative menée pour la
deuxième année consécutive par le
collège Sainte-Thérèse du
Mesnil-Saint-Denis et les élèves de 4e
ont préparé Germinal de Zola qu'il
présenteront ce vendredi le monde est à
la fois artistique et mécanique des chez
les marionnettes en festival le
rédacteur d'ailleurs dédié jusqu'au la
voie d'artistes là se passe à la ferme
de La Tremblaye vous en avez vu quelques
images et puis elle le portrait de
Matthieu Dupuy ancien joueur du club de
rugby de Montigny et qui évolue à
présent au Stade Français dans la
catégorie des moins de 19 ans et les
Crabos il est revenu sur les terrains de
ses débuts à l'occasion d'une rencontre
face à Lille
le mercredi dans le 7 8 c'est aussi
l'heure de la culture avec Aurélia
domicile bonsoir Aurélien et tout à
l'heure au cours de la page culture dans
un peu moins d'une demi-heure nous
évoquons un festival de musique à
Voisins-le-Bretonneux et puis un
spectacle de danse à La Verrière
exactement donc il s'agit de rencontre
chorégraphiques donc qui auront lieu le
13 avril prochain donc à la verrière en
fait globalement c'est de la danse et
dont l'objectif est de soutenir la
recherche dans la lutte contre la
sclérose en plaques donc nous en
parlerons tout à l'heure et nous
partirons ensuite du côté de voisins
Bretonneux cette fois-ci pour un concert
dancehall dont l'intitulé passe le
message à tous voisins donc nous verrons
de quoi il s'agit
tout à l'heure on peut déjà le dévoiler
Tonton David et notamment à l'affiche
avec nous tout à l'heure vous l'avez
vous avez changé avec lui ce matin
l'interview sera retrouvé dans un peu
moins d'une demi-heure pour l'instant on
passe au fait du jour ce coup d'envoi du
Sidaction 2013
et la fiche de cette édition 2013 du
Sidaction vous allez la découvrir avec
ce mot d'ordre contre le sida ne crayon
pas victoire trop vite je vous
demanderai président d'achève prévention
association basée à Villepreux qui
intervient dans le département des
Yvelines depuis peu dans le Val-de-Marne
l'Essonne la Seine-et-Marne également
vous faites de la prévention auprès de
différents publics lorsqu'on voit ce mot
d'ordre cette année sur cette affiche ne
crions pas victoire trop vite ça veut
dire que dans l'esprit de chacun
aujourd'hui le SIDAM fait plus peur tout
simplement le vrai souci c'est que il y
a effectivement une avancée
thérapeutique et heureusement d'ailleurs
à la fois pour les gens qui sont
séropositif et j'ai des gens qui ne sont
pas parce qu'effectivement on est quand
même aujourd'hui avec une séropositivité
qu'on arrive plus ou moins à gérer avec
beaucoup d'effets secondaires et sans en
discutera avec Xavier mais c'est vrai
que pour le coup les associations
avaient espéré que le sida c'était
bientôt fini et il avait un peu trop
crié trop fort c'est le cas de le dire
on a eu des mots d'ordre ou
effectivement on disait bientôt le sida
c'est c'est terminé si on arrive à
dépister les 50 000 personnes qui sont
donc enfin qui qui s'ignor et en réalité
on se rend bien compte qu'aujourd'hui le
SIDA on n'arrive pas à s'en
débattouiller et que on a toujours 6 à
7000 cartes de contamination chaque
année et de plus en plus d'ailleurs avec
des jeunes et c'est bien ce qui
inquiétant vous qui êtes séropositifs
justement lorsque vous entendez jusque
ce mot d'ordre cette année c'est ne
crayons pas victoire trop vite et que
vous voyez certaines personnes peut-être
ne plus craindre le sida vous réagissez
comment c'est extrêmement important
parce qu'effectivement quand on va le
sida ça pose tout un tas de problèmes
d'exclusion sociale de lourdeur des
traitements qui sont encore même s'ils
sont bien plus facile à prendre que
qu'autrefois il reste quand même très
lourd ça demande un suivi d'aller voir
d'aller régulièrement à l'hôpital c'est
quand même des choses qui sont très
lourdes donc je souhaite à personne donc
c'est important de se faire dépister et
si on veut arrêter l'épidémie
effectivement il faut que les personnes
aillent se faire dépister et leur
montrer que oui maintenant on peut faire
des choses on peut le faire de plus en
plus tôt et c'est ça qui est intéressant
donc il y a vraiment des désavancées
mais c'est pas suffisant voilà donc on
est je dirais un peu au milieu du gué
continuons on a fait des très belles
choses
formidable mais mais on peut faire
encore mieux et je crois que le sida
montré qu'il y avait une mobilisation de
toute la société pour pouvoir
freiner cette épidémie et un jour
peut-être la réduire le sédaction c'est
aussi l'occasion de faire des dons un
numéro de téléphone c'est le 110 numéro
qui restera actif jusqu'au 18 avril vous
pouvez le composer je rappelle les dates
du Sidaction les trois jours à partir du
5 6 et 7 avril le numéro de téléphone
lui est accessible jusqu'au 18 avril à
l'occasion du Sidaction quel message
vous aimeriez faire passer justement moi
je pense que c'est important on parle
beaucoup de solidarité et c'est
important de que la solidarité se
traduise par le soutien justement à la
recherche par ce soutien aux
associations
ça c'est quelque chose d'important les
personnes ont besoin de montrer aussi
quelles sont solidaires donc il y a un
acte et on voit bien qu'il y a une
dynamique et qui est une amie qui est
exceptionnelle ce lien entre les
patients et la recherche et moi je
travaille beaucoup dans la recherche je
suis pas chercheur je suis patient et
c'est une implication qui est tout à
fait originale et qui était reproduire
sur d'autres maladies également et ça se
fait ça commence à se faire mais pas
encore assez donc je pense qu'il faut
prendre cet exemple et ça va au-delà du
du VIH ou de la bucides contre le sida
ne crayon pas victoire trop vite c'est
le mode ordre de cette année notre
question aujourd'hui elle est toute
simple le sida vous fait-il encore peur
c'est toujours un sujet d'actualité
effectivement il faut toujours s'en
inquiéter et si ça se répand c'est qu'il
y a peut-être pas suffisamment de
prévention il y a plein de gens qui ont
le sida et qu'ils savent pas donc pour
t'exprimer importante moi ça me fait pas
spécialement peur moi je préfère la
fidélité au préservatif si c'est
apprendre
ouais ça me fait toujours peur parce que
j'en connais qui n'utilise toujours pas
de préservatif et je trouve ça quand
même assez grave et donc c'est important
que d'en parler toujours
ça me fait pas peur non je me protège et
voilà oui ça nous fait peur parce que
aujourd'hui en Afrique il y a beaucoup
de gens qui décèdent par rapport au VIH
bah il y a pas les mois moi je trouve
aussi le sida c'est une maladie qui
atteint plus les pauvres
les gens qui vit dans un environnement
qui n'est pas du tout propre
la dernière remarque qu'on a entendu et
pas tellement fausse ça peut aussi
toucher des gens qui sont peut-être
aussi moins moins informés c'est aussi
votre travail avec HF prévention d'aller
à la rencontre de ces populations c'est
effectivement qu'il y a une précarité
qui fait que les gens peuvent être plus
facilement au contact de personnes
effectivement qui qui vont être malade
pas seulement d'ailleurs c'est au
positive et tout l'enjeu c'est
effectivement d'être dans un aller vers
les populations invisibles nous c'est
tout notre travail à chefréhension et
depuis d'ailleurs donc la fin d'année
dernière on en avait donc parlé on va
maintenant beaucoup plus facilement en
université mais aussi en centre
commerciaux parce qu'on imagine que les
populations à risque on va le rappeler
les migrants les homosexuels notamment
mais pas seulement les personnes en
situation de prostitution sont des
publics effectivement à risque et ce
qu'on aime bien rappeler aussi c'est que
c'est important de dire que ces publics
là sont partout y compris dans les
centres commerciaux et pas toujours dans
les familles grands ou pas que dans le
Marais parisien et que du coup il y a
une vraie incidence d'aller vers eux
parce que on oublie trop souvent que ce
sont des gens qui sont effectivement
invisibles et qui n'ont pas forcément
accès ni aux dépistage ni effectivement
à l'information et là ça reste important
on va juste regarder à présent le
chiffre du jour le chiffre de cette
édition c'est 72 72 heures trois jours
consacrés aussi d'action est-ce que
c'est suffisant ces trois jours de
mobilisation malheureusement non ce
n'est pas suffisant alors nous on aime
bien dire que le Sidaction aussi c'est
toute l'année parce qu'il faut savoir
qu'on peut donner toute l'année on peut
aussi faire des legs aussi d'action faut
savoir que pour un euro donné aussi
d'action 50% donc 50 centimes partent à
la recherche le sédaction a toujours
souhaité soutenir la recherche et l'une
des seules organisations a vraiment bien
soutenir donc les programmes de
recherche en direction du sida et les 50
centimes restants sont partagés sur les
programmes associatifs 25 centimes sur
la France dont nous puisqu'on est
financé donc si l'action à HF prévention
et 25 centimes pour les programmes
internationaux donc effectivement pour 1
euro reversé l'intégralité des dons des
gens vont pour la cause qu'elles soient
dans la recherche ou dans le soutien
donc aux personnes ou dans le soutien la
prévention on va parler de prévention
encore pendant les prochaines minutes on
va parler de votre quotidien également
de votre témoignage vous qui êtes je
vous le disais tout à l'heure
séropositif depuis 1987 vous vivez avec
la maladie au quotidien vous témoignerez
dans un instant on regarde juste le clip
de cette édition du Sidaction édition
quel est le quotidien Aujourd'hui
justement pour une personne atteinte par
le sida quelle est votre quotidien
Aujourd'hui le mon quotidien c'est c'est
d'abord la prise des traitements une à
deux fois par jour avec parfois des
effets secondaires je dirais même
souvent des effets secondaires qui sont
souvent des modifications ça se voit pas
trop chez moi j'ai eu un peu de chance
mais tout le monde a pas cette chance là
on a effectivement des des problèmes de
graisse et puis peut-être probablement
de un vieillissement accéléré et ça
c'est quand même ça pose des problèmes
des petits problèmes de perte de mémoire
éventuellement des choses comme ça
chaque personne est individuelle on est
tous différents donc on va réagir
différemment en tout cas les premiers
mois de traitement sont les traitements
qui sont assez lourds après c'est un peu
plus léger mais le plus léger c'est
quand même les traitements tous les
jours il faut pas les oublier le
médicament vous devez prendre ça fait
pas beaucoup ça fait deux médicaments le
matin de médicaments le soir ça fait pas
beaucoup aujourd'hui
mais c'est quand même des médicaments
qui sont aussi de la chimiothérapie faut
jamais l'oublier quand même et ça ne
guérit pas du ciné c'est à dire ça ça
freine
que vous avez le sida pas forcément
avoir envie de sortir avec vous tout de
suite un peu compliqué là justement
est-ce que le regard a évolué tout de
même aussi au-delà de justement des
personnes qui peuvent partager votre de
votre quotidien mais le regard de la
société en général je sens pas que le
regard de la société est beaucoup évolué
sur sur le sujet il y a beaucoup je
discutais encore avec le vigile de de la
Faculté des Sciences à Pitié-Salpêtrière
qui disait qui se laver les mains et qui
était très effrayé quand je lui ai serré
la main et pourtant il est au cœur de de
1000 étudiants en médecine non non il y
a encore beaucoup beaucoup de travail
c'est normal la culture c'est quelque
chose de toujours lent à changer mais
c'est pour ça que des émissions en faire
un refaire c'est très important
aujourd'hui le VIH il se transmet par
voie sanguine par voie sexuelle quand
les gens ne sont pas traités c'est pour
ça qu'il faut les traiter quand on est
traité il y a pas de risque bien sûr il
faut utiliser la capote parce qu'il y a
des tas d'autres cochonneries des tas de
maladies qui peuvent arriver mais
sans sans concrètement là il y a un vrai
risque effectivement c'est important de
le rappeler de le rappeler régulièrement
et nous le faisons encore une fois ce
soir c'est le travail d'achève
prévention on l'a mentionné tout à
l'heure on a aussi vu des images tout à
l'heure pendant que nous parlions de ces
interventions que vous faites dans les
universités avec ces tests de dépistage
test minutes justement qui permettent de
savoir immédiatement on en avait parlé
d'ailleurs ici sur ce plateau
aujourd'hui il y a trop de personnes qui
ignorent justement le fait de d'être
porteur porteuse de la maladie le
ministère estime entre 30 et 50 000
personnes qui ne connaissent pas leur
statut sérologique et qui sont donc en
capacité de transmettre le VIH et comme
le disait tout à l'heure Xavier
aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui est traité
peut être en ce qu'on appelle une charge
virale indétectable et donc ne plus
transmettre le virus à condition qu'ils
prennent bien ses médicaments et qui a
une belle une bonne observance et qui
est pas de souci par ailleurs ce qui
pose un vrai problème c'est
effectivement le fait d'avoir des gens
qui sont ça au positif qui ne le savent
pas qui ne vont pas systématiquement
faire un dépistage aujourd'hui un centre
de dépistage anon bien gratuit un cddhg
faisait en moyenne 0,2% de découverte
nous on a démontré que Ed qui par
exemple intervient dans le milieu gay ou
les faux immigrants fait 1%
malheureusement et moi je ne peux dire
que malheureusement on est à 2,34 % sur
les lieux ou interviennent à chaque fois
parce qu'on est au cœur de des gens qui
ne vont jamais en centre de dépistage et
au cœur du problème qui est ces gens qui
n'ont pas conscience que le VIH peut
être effectivement transmis d'où
l'intérêt que le Sidaction en
l'occurrence finance des programmes
comme les nôtres qui sont des programmes
vraiment atypiques et d'où l'intérêt
effectivement que les gens continuent à
donner pour le sélection ce test en
minutes vous l'avez ramené le petit
plateau on peut le remonter ce serait
très très simple effectivement éducative
donc l'idée c'est effectivement de
recueillir une à deux gouttes 3 maximum
gouttes 200 dans une pipette et en fait
à l'aide des flacons donc qui sont
numérotés 1 2 3 on va en fait avoir le
résultat immédiat alors effectivement
les cinq continents vont découvrir la
campagne de communication qu'on a qui
est une minute pour savoir qui est édité
non par un chef prévention mais cela dit
on va effectivement gagner les centres
commerciaux les universités on espère
d'ailleurs que le centre commercial
Espace 50 ans
on devrait effectivement donc pouvoir
proposer ces dates en même temps que le
forum santé donc de 50 ans en Yvelines
on espère juste qu'on aura donc l'accord
et ça permettra de pouvoir donc proposer
ce dépistage directement donc au grand
public qui est aussi le public cible
parce que aujourd'hui le public ne va
plus véritablement sur les lieux
d'information je pense au Christ aux
Crips par exemple sur Paris le clip à
Paris c'est essentiellement pour les
lycées CFA parfois les collèges ils vont
etc mais l'idée c'est vraiment que on se
rend bien compte moi quand je vais dans
une fac et qu'on me dit une jeune femme
de 22 23 ans qui me dit je ne vais pas
chez le gynécologue ou alors qui me dit
en fin de compte je qui protéger j'ai
pas besoin de mettre de préservatif
parce que j'ai effectivement la pilule
on lui dit non enfin la pilule c'est
pour la contraception ça vous empêche de
faire des bébés mais ça vous empêche pas
d'avoir toutes les maladies qui vont
autour et on parle pas que du VIH du
SIDA on parle aussi donc de toutes les
infections sexuellement transmissibles
il y a une recrudescence de plein de
maladies sexuelles en ce moment on dit
juste aux gens qu'à un moment donné la
réduction des risques tout n'est pas
100% préservatif mais c'est bien aussi
de venir en discuter avec nos animateurs
de prévention qui sont jeunes d'ailleurs
et qui sont ultra formés à ces questions
là et qui viennent directement à la
rencontre donc du public on est aussi à
50 ans en Yvelines puisque Île-de-France
Ouest à chef François Île-de-France
ouest assez bureaux donc à l'Institut de
promotion de la santé et c'est pas rare
voilà donc à part à Trappes et c'est pas
rare que des gens viennent nous
rencontrer pour nous poser donc des
questions qui parfois pour eux sont
bêtes mais il n'y a pas de question bête
et ils ont raison de venir nous voir ces
tests qui se multiplient et entre par la
suite aussi les autotests on en a pas
parlé mais là qui permettrait à chacun
de savoir tout seul et peut-être même
s'il faut ensuite voir que les gens vont
l'apprendre tout seul et il y aura pas
d'encadrement psychologique et là aussi
c'est important au-delà de ça tout de
même ces tests qui se multiplient test
minutes vous c'est une bonne chose moi
je pense que c'est formidable c'est
c'est important si j'avais eu ça c'est
aussi une sensibilisation et puis c'est
aussi une démarche de soins on est dans
une civilisation où on commence à
s'aperçoit que la santé c'est
extrêmement important c'est c'est c'est
mais il faut y aller et se soigner
soi-même avoir la démarche et ben c'est
pas si facile que ça on n'a pas tout à
fait l'éducation qui va pour se soigner
soi-même se prendre soin c'est c'est une
démarche il faut la travailler il faut
que que ça vienne petit à petit dans
notre culture on a à manger on a des
écrans télé Plats on a des tas de trucs
formidables mais la santé c'est quand
même essentiel et essayer de quelque
chose qu'on a du mal encore à ce que ça
soit fluide voilà et c'était justement
permettre cette fluidité il y aura des
tests encore plus plus sophistiqués dans
les années qui vont venir qui
permettront de faire encore plus
d'autres maladies avec les hépatites
nous on espère sortir enfin sortir on va
proposer probablement en combinaison
avec le sida des tests sur la syphilis
recrudescence de syphilis sont en
imagine même pas enfin franchement c'est
juste une catastrophe et effectivement
le fait d'avoir des tests qui seront
combinés ça permettra de pouvoir
proposer une vraie prévention et une
avec des réponses immédiates quoi date
du Sidaction 5 6 et 7 avril vendredi
soir il y aura une collecte aussi vous
êtes la facture avec vous voilà
exactement à donner donc effectivement
on va donc proposer ça à la gare de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines l'idée c'est
que les gens puissent mettre dans les
tirelires du Sidaction pour la quête
nationale donc du Sidaction encore une
fois donc le 110 ou aussi par sms ou
directement sur le site internet de
sédaction mais on peut aussi donner à la
gare de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines nous
on y sera donc de 16 heures à peu près
jusqu'à 20h l'idée c'est effectivement
que chacun puisse mettre une petite
pièce pour que le Sidaction donc puisse
continuer à soutenir et la recherche et
les programmes associatifs est-ce que
vous avez besoin de bénévoles aussi
parce qu'il y a beaucoup d'opération
dont on a parlé là on merci beaucoup
besoin de bénévoles puisque
effectivement l'idée c'est de faire
toutes les facs en Île-de-France
notamment ainsi que les centres
commerciaux et du coup on forme
gratuitement il y a une batterie de
formation qui est assez colossale donc
les gens qui n'y connaissent rien ce
n'est pas un souci on les forme il y a
aucun problème et ensuite effectivement
on a besoin de beaucoup de bénévoles
beaucoup de brins beaucoup de gens de
bonne volonté et à partir du moment où
les gens de la bonne volonté peuvent
nous contacter sur notre site internet
qui est
www.hf1 qui s'est affiché numéro de
téléphone également je rappelle l'autre
numéro de téléphone à composer et
jusqu'au 18 avril c'est le 110 pour
faire directement vos dons merci à tous
les deux on a évoqué tout à l'heure très
brièvement les auto-testes juste une
précision il pourrait faire leur
apparition à la fin du mois de septembre
puisque le 22 mars dernier le Conseil
national du sida présenté un avis en
faveur de la mise à disposition donc de
ces auto-testes vous accueillez plutôt
c'est en réponse à ce que demande la
ministre clairement puisqu'ils avaient
ils avaient donné des avis donc négatifs
avant nous on n'est pas favorable parce
qu'on estime que que même s'il y a un
numéro où les gens quand ils seront
séropositifs pourront appeler on trouve
que c'est pas bien qu'il puisse
découvrir seul leur séropositivité s'il
y a pas un vrai encadrement
par exemple oui oui il faut de
préférence mais en même temps pour
comment dire pour il faut pouvoir
inonder de avec des approches
complètement différentes et elles vont
même si elle est minoritaires il faut
pas la sous-estimer il faut que ça reste
une possibilité voilà il faut plein de
de choses différentes et puis rien
n'empêche chacun s'il a besoin aussi
d'encadrement de se tourner vers les
associations nous inquiète aussi c'est
la fiabilité du test donc là on attend
et aussi que les tests soient beaucoup
plus fiables ce qui est pas le cas
aujourd'hui alors on rappelle quand même
que celui-ci qu'on propose c'est
99,9%
les tests instit c'est du 99,9%, il y a
pas de défaillance donc effectivement là
on est sûr du produit qu'on propose pour
les gens quoi et en plus vous êtes
encadré puisque vous faites ce travail
d'accompagnement merci une fois de plus
à tous les deux si l'action à partir du
5 avril le 7 8 de ce 3 avril le lui se
poursuit nous évoquons les Journées
Européennes de l'artisanat dans un
instant avec de nouveaux invités mais
déjà un portrait un portrait de sportif
celui de Mathieu dupuff c'est un ancien
joueur du club de Montigny-le-Bretonneux
de rugby il évolue maintenant au Stade
Français avec les moins de 19 ans
rencontre sur le terrain de ses débuts
avec Anthony Rech et Claire Cambier
chez les du pif le rugby est une
tradition Mathieu suit les traces de son
père et de son oncle tous les deux
anciens piliers après des débuts en
Ardèche il joue sous les couleurs de la
SMV rugby pendant trois ans trois
saisons qui vont être décisives bien
encadrés à Montigny match décolle et
passe les détections pour intégrer
l'équipe cadet du Stade Français en
réalité quand il est allé faire les
détections il voulait savoir s'il
pouvait exister à ce niveau-là si avoir
l'ambition d'être dans un grand club
avec une concurrence exacerbée ce qui
n'était pas le cas à Montigny il n'était
pas dans une concurrence exacerbée
est-ce qu'il arriverait à s'en sortir
Matthieu vit 4 5 premiers mois très
difficiles mais il s'accroche et finit
par s'intégrer dans l'effectif parisien
les structures du Stade Français ne
pouvant accueillir tous les matchs les
craboss les moins de 19 ans doivent
jouer systématiquement sur des pelouses
différentes en ce week-end de Pâques
Montigny accueille la rencontre face à
Lille c'est très sympa on avait joué un
match à hernir le 16e de finale contre
contre Massy on l'avait joué ici aussi
c'était très sympa en plus il y a un
super terrain que c'est un terrain de
foot donc il est pas très abîmé il est
bien entretenu et donc bah ça fait
plaisir de venir on est je suis content
mais ce retour sur ces terres a un goût
d'inachevé le pilier ENI monte un
souffre d'une entorse à la cheville
gauche et doit regarder le match des
tribunes désormais bien installé dans le
groupe stade 10 depuis 3 saisons Mathieu
reste très pragmatique sur son avenir
j'ai un niveau correct certes mais pas
forcément pour aller en professionnel
donc bah pour l'instant je vais au Stade
Français je suis content j'y reste je
vais continuer à essayer de grappiller
du temps de jeu et à jouer le plus
possible et de prendre du contenu à
prendre du plaisir puis après on
Seigneur on verra peut-être
j'irai peut-être en troisième peut-être
une division pour jouer dans un dans un
autre club peut-être qui m'aidera à
faire mes études ensuite Mathieu dupiff
prépare un baccalauréat scientifique
pour ensuite intégrer une faculté de
sport ah oui pour la petite histoire
c'est coéquipier se sont imposés 29 à 10
face à Lille